rated T for teen  a few months ago the yukl saved my life  they found me when I was dying next to a  river in the West of Siberia and took me  in Dokdo they are accompanying the  migration of the snow ostriches to their  sacred lands  it's a long journey a very special  journey today I'm just trying to help  kate walker will always represent a  problem for us I will do what it takes  colonel  migration must continue no time to lose  protect the UCLES from those criminals  you can count on me  the soldiers we have to go  Cape Walker no leave me alone do calm  down it's for your own good  whether you like  or not  you can't go to there anymore  the Yuka Caravan absolutely must  continue on its migration do you  understand  Oscar  come on come get some  no way I'm going back now that I'm so  close  [Music]